[Musique]
pny
pertinents
mais
oui
amiens temps c'est un peu l'un des
militants et membres à voir donc un peu
les filles j'ai pensé à des conseils à
la lettre je mets m
les joueurs car pas lésés d'oise pendant
que ma mère du bet
oui il était
tu as maintenant si t'as pas des
militants en démentant boire donc un peu
les filles avec ma môme hier soir devant
tu passerais ben on en fait y avait de
la gueule
[Musique]
m
oui mais
tu as bien d'avoir des militants rend
vraiment pas moi laisse donc un peu mais
via les majors
non
[Musique]
m
je m'impose que moi vous méritez
vraiment
chacune des douze jours 20 films en
quarts
[Musique]
très vite
oui il aime les filles de câliner de
caresser journée croit voir toi et méfie
[Musique]
toi aimer des fils et des filles
eh bien
line renaud il faut maintenant présenter
aux téléspectateurs
le jeune johnny hallyday qui a votre
filleul qui vient de chanter et bien
johnny hallyday venait il a 16 ans je
crois du soc 17 voyez ça change tout je
voudrais bien poser des questions à mon
filleul mais je vous préviens tout de
suite mais il répond par oui ou par non
c'est monsieur ruines c'est monsieur oui
non et je crois qu'on doit sa la
timidité de ses 17 ans alors si vraiment
c'est moi qui lui vaut une question
pourquoi s'appelle-t-il johnny hallyday
il s'appelle johnny hallyday parce que
son père s'appelle hallyday c'est tout
simple il fallait y penser
le prix d'amérique le père est américain
et la maman français alors c'est un
produit à moitié français moitié
amérique est la chanson qui dit elle
chante et laisse les filles le village
proche je suppose que c'est un conseil
de sa mère non pourquoi ça vous
intéresse les filles comme neymar eu
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que j'ai pas
compris que ça y est il a dit autre
chose que nous l'avions l'a dit bien ce
but assez bien johnny vous fait des
progrès déjà voyez vous est ce que c'est
votre premier choix sont pourtant sans
faire d'autres bien sûr bien sûr
valables
julan et bien et bien sûr maintenant et
et bien je crois que pour ça il faut le
demander aux téléspectateurs parce que à
la fin de tout c'est le public qui est
seul juge
moi je vous ai présenté mon filleul à
bien savoir s'il a une carrière devant
lui ou s'il n'en a pas en tout cas on
lui dit bonne chance et on lui dit de
s'en aller parce que j'ai deux mois dire
à l'innoparc eu l'excusé nous maintenant
nous rentrerons
[Musique]